hello and welcome to this video what is
this he said this that try phone show
that's probably his show right he is
playing in the five minute pool I don't
really know you never we don't play all
that often we have totally different
times I think when we log on
he plays early mornings mostly and well
I don't why should I be sure to get rid
of the analysis view that weird gray
square so what is it coming up with you
it's a it's a it's a scotch
yep that cannot be bad develop stuff
however here what has to be a little bit
careful
after f3 I think d5 should be annoying
I'm not quite sure I mean I'm not really
threatening to take only four because
there is a think Bishop of seven tech
tech here so if you place like rookie
one I think 94-94 rupee form
yeah as I mentioned I don't think this
is strictly necessary to do okay um I
think I don't know - do that
ninety-fourth also move actually ninety
four ninety six ninety three years
Bishop of seven whoa I can take deep oil
play d4 to d5 which is that the simple
thing to do but I don't know I think I
think I can do this first
and then decide what to do yeah 94 is
something that I was thinking about he
cannot move the bishop st for his
hanging
maybe this Nets me the bishop pam is
their tactic for him well do I want to
take on a three and open up the air file
if you ask me I don't want to do that so
let's play sound and solid here with d5
giving him an IQ peel I mean white is
fine it should be active enough look 81
for example it cannot be bad okay so I
didn't want you open up the air phone
I'm just going to support this night
okay so let's be quick here and see I
want to attack deform and at the same
time allow Bishop f5 okay so he's
attacking h7 if I go g6 there's night
reform it's somewhat annoying 94 maybe
h6 is better
I think best Bishop f5 now is a where
threat is a bit strong but an idea at
least if I just take on you for them and
that's a very simplistic approach I
don't know if this is really good okay
um f5 looks wrong I still think this
should be fine
should be fine actually
maybe you just moves the c1 bishop I
don't see a tactic here like a knight f6
okay he can play that but it should not
bother me all that much if I take the
form what is the point here isn't that a
pawn for not much don't see the catch so
I'll take the pawn
yeah god I think I just snatched this
pony right since I mean maybe you should
yeah
trading cannot help wider all that much
on d4 I mean so maybe we should see one
back or something but it doesn't know
doesn't inspire much confidence
what can still try it with the with the
bishops okay so he decided to trade
after all yeah
the bishop is it's not as not so useful
here I have might have six in most cases
where I'm covering
okay I take a1 and Knight f6 hmm and
then we should move is irritating do
have some other tactic here I don't know
come on come on keep it simple anything
else
I don't think so let's just do this
that's a clean way of playing attacking
the bishop twice most endings are very
very favorable I don't need to do
anything anything fancy here in the
middle of the board cannot be that bad
so look e8 little mate fret g60 probably
take that's not something I would like
to see him Queen e2 maybe I don't know
if I want to trade Queens here strictly
no it's probably not bad rook e8 f 98
night against Bishop ending would be
very to be quite suitable to win I think
I just have the majority going for me
maybe I should have checked her actually
maybe okay
so if I check and ke7
I'm having a good control yeah I have to
be careful here not to fall behind on
the clock all that much okay so here
ninety-five beef b5 I can also do this
this is also not bad and then bringing
the King over this is actually very
sound oh I didn't see there hi morning I
didn't see that coming at all okay I
hope it's not a big issue
when I was a funny one but I don't need
to take yeah he only has a check ha
so here Bishop shake that can also go
here immediately and now see that I can
move the pawns would be 5 and stuff yet
let's get going here b5 nice where I'm
taking anything there can you look at
three as well let's go again three just
attack the a spawn 29 seconds actually
she paid more attention to that bloody
pawn down but okay
Oh No what cook I didn't think of this
at all yeah oh my god okay check check
check check
Oh game tough game to a final seconds oh
wow
okay so let's let's see how this how
this panned out oh okay there's some of
the times are not displayed I think I
have to get a new game board going to
get this into the
into the mix maybe I should let me try
if I can do this
I know it's that's crazy I'm sorry about
that I think I can probably do it like
this I'm not mistaken and now we should
also have the time soon
yep okay so let's do it like that I want
to see the clock times in some cases so
Queens - - yeah I was thinking about
this roof but I told I don't know if I
want to take that they know they have
their far I wasn't really sure about it
and especially here but I think g5 is a
decent choice can get the engine like
that it should be six yeah maybe six
well that should be comfortable I have a
very young harmonious entire iqp
position this and g6 I wasn't sure I
know Bishop f5 yeah okay the engine
basically agrees with what I'm doing
so I've won this pawn and now it wants
to play 93 yeah well I saw the move but
I wasn't sure if it really is better
maybe it is yeah because of poor
instruction yeah it gives him a further
port for the big pond so I was I was
kind of I would like the knight on f6
because this is such a harmonious
situation yeah okay the engine no woods
to play g6 but and I saw those I saw
some ideas yeah like I have fun Knight
to g4 man maybe lucky I have 94 twin but
I think it really I didn't want to do
any anything like that yeah even if he's
not meeting me I don't want that so I
just wanted to have a clean technical
situation but I screw it up I mean I'm
happy with with all up to here because
black is completely winning a bunch in
the time scram but I did something
stupid I think all this is basically
fine
and somewhere around here I definitely
could have done things things better so
here let's see I went here King up
before King g4c for all that should be
okay this and now here it still wins
that doesn't win yeah I was kind of this
disorientated me to no end but now I
have C - yeah that was the thing that
that that I did I that I missed and then
I've also never check here also like
here it's check yeah let's check and the
end it gives me plus a million so I'm
winning this probably with with some
chicks and here g8 was draw really this
is a draw check yeah it's a calendar
check oh my god it's a counter check ooh
I already saw that I come up again and
then I promote let's check but but it's
it's a it's a check him he has a chicken
sale huh right here this is a potential
okay so this is could have saved him and
now everything was was host back in
order so to save clock was like before
wow I was a tough game really good a
fighting at the end okay guys thanks for
watching